le concept des petites cités de
caractère valorise des communes atypique
tonnerre a reçu ce label officiellement
le mois dernier c'est la seule commune
de bourgogne franche comté à avoir cette
distinction fait le point tout de suite
avec françois prudent il est en direct
et en duplex vous voudrez bien venu dans
la matinale alors deux ans après avoir
préparé le dossier ça y'est tonnerre est
devenue petite cité de caractère un
atout touristique indéniable ça c'est
clair
je vous propose de regarder le reportage
de stéphane robert et yoann etienne et
puis on en parle tout de suite après son
imposant de toiture ne passe pas
inaperçu l'hôtel dieu et bien l'endroit
touristique incontournable de la ville
un peu plus loin la fosse dionne
s'offrent aux touristes
cette famille des alentours de tonnerre
revient régulièrement avec plaisir
visiter ou revisiter cette source
alimenté en permanence
audrey vite à paris elle veut maintenant
faire découvrir au plus grand nombre
l'eau turquoise qui a baigné son enfance
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit un peu
mystérieux quand j'étais petit
voilà ça me faisait rêver et maintenant
je viens la filmer en 360 pour essayer
de montrer un peu au monde la fosse
dionne est de faire connaître la cause
gay et j'espère que de nombreux
touristes vont venir pour découvrir cet
endroit la ville très charmante un
charme que tonnerre veut continuer de
faire fructifier
il faut avoir l'oeil pour le remarquer
mais les panneaux d'entrée de ville
signale que cette commune de plus de
5000 habitants fait depuis peu partie du
réseau de petites cités de caractère
ce label est décerné à de petites
communes dotées d'un bâti architectural
de qualité ces communes s'engage en
contrepartie à le mettre en valeur
auprès des habitants et des visiteurs
dans le cadre donc des petites cités de
caractère nous avons créé un fonds
petite cité de caractère qui permet à
l'ensemble des propriétaires sur le
secteur sauvegardé d'avoir des fonds
disponibles pour améliorer donc les
toitures les façades de faire de la
rénovation donc ça c'est un atout
économique puisque ça met en avant la
possibilité à des artisans de travailler
et de rénover notre bâti et des
curiosités tonnerre ne manquent pas si
ce label met en avant le caractère
monumental du patrimoine il vit
si le patrimoine culturel comme dans cet
hôtel particulier qui accueille les
collections de la ville et recèle de
belles histoires
notamment celle du chevalier d'éon ici
vous avez une gravure de cet homme
illustre très très connu hors des
frontières françaises
mais et qui mériterait tout à fait de
retrouver sa place au centre de la ville
et ce label petite cité de caractère
c'est justement promouvoir tous les
éléments qui permettront demain à
tonnerre de reprendre sa place dans
l'histoire de france et aussi dans le
coeur des français tonnerre est à ce
jour la seule ville de bourgogne franche
comté à être inscrits dans ce réseau est
en france il y en a un peu plus un peu
plus de 150 communes à avoir ce label
donc vous en faites partie maintenant et
qu'est ce que ça change est ce que vous
avez des obligations oui on a des
contraintes de préservation comme l'a
indiqué madame le maire préservation du
patrimoine
et puis c'est pas une ville musée ce
label c'est aussi une ville dynamique
donc il ya aussi des obligations
d'animation culturelle associative
donc c'est vraiment d'essayer d'attirer
un tourisme et derrière c'est contre un
c'est de valoriser au maximum ce
patrimoine tout en le rendant dynamique
et vivant actuelle ça veut dire qu'avant
vous ne faisait pas forcément si on va
dire que historiquement ya pas besoin du
label pour reconnaître que tonnerre est
une petite ville deux caractères s'était
fait depuis des décennies par les
municipalités qui se sont succédé mais
c'est vrai que ce label permet de
rentrer en résonance avec tout un réseau
comme vous l'avait indiqué il ya 150
villes en france qui sont petites cités
de caractère et c'est vrai qu'à
proximité de tonnerre il y en a
quelques-unes juste de l'autre côté dans
l'eau mais c'est vrai qu'en bourgogne
franche comté il n'y en a pas et c'est
vrai que tonnerre bénéficie finalement
d'une mise en lumière du fait de ce
label finalement si je vous comprends
bien le label est une continuité de
toutes les démarches que vous avez déjà
entreprises tout à fait une continuité
ça te permet de donner un coup de
projecteur il faut bien comprendre que
le touriste aujourd'hui en un clic ils
changent de ville
il change de territoire il peut même
changer de continent donc ce label
permet de vraiment de donner un coup de
projecteur
on le fait également aujourd'hui grâce à
votre reportage ça permet à tonnerre de
ressortir par par rapport à un
territoire
ça s'inscrit dans une démarche globale
cette année ces petites cités de
caractère pour la ville de tonnerre et
puis dans quelques mois il va y avoir le
lancement du routard le long et autour
du canal de bourgogne
donc on est vraiment dans une dynamique
territoriale une mise en réseau et
petites cités de caractère est un label
structurant pour la ville de tonnerre et
son territoire pourquoi parlez-vous du
canal ça veut dire que ça va englober
vraiment plusieurs secteurs riders de
tonnerre alors petite cité de caractère
bien évidemment on va se concentrer sur
le le coeur historique de la ville
mais la municipalité a des projets aussi
de de reconnecter complètement le canal
de bourgogne le port de tonnerre et puis
justement ce coeur historique
il ne faut pas qu'on crée des des
enclaves parce que on aurait un label
non la municipalité travaille avec
l'ensemble des acteurs pour qu'ils y ait
une vraie continuité touristique au sein
de la ville au niveau du port et
finalement avec le canal qui génère un
flux touristique très important
finalement une dynamique de territoire
oui c'est une dynamique de territoire
aujourd'hui tonnerre est mise en avant
on espère que d'autres cités qui sont
tout simplement sur ce linéaire
touristique du canal de bourgogne vont
s'inscrire dans cette démarche
qu'elle soit dans l'yonne où qu'elles
soient en côte d'or pour finalement
créer un réseau qui s'autoalimenterait
ce que c'est vrai comme vous l'avez
souligné il n'y a qu'une ville en
bourgogne franche comté comme tonnerre
qui fait partie du réseau
mais comme je le dis on allait des
communes voisines comme ervy le châtel
qui est distante de quelques dizaines de
kilomètres qui est dans l'aube et qui
fait partie aussi de ce réseau donc les
touristes d'un point de vue je dirais
fonctionnement ben ne connaissent pas
les limites administratives donc
tonnerre a cette chance pour le moment
d'être la seule mais elles espèrent être
rejoints par d'autres
est ce que ça veut dire que au niveau
des services que vous allez proposer aux
touristes
et bien vous allez l'étoffé entre halte
vélo les gîtes
alors il ya ce que la collectivité met
en oeuvre ce que met la municipalité
l'intercommunauté via son office du
tourisme
et puis aussi ce que met en oeuvre le
secteur privé toute la partie
hébergement gîtes va tirer bénéfice
finalement de ce label parce que ça crée
des besoins il faut répondre aux besoins
des touristes
alors on les anticipe au maximum la
période justement hivernale et une
période où il ya la réflexion un travail
de fond notamment il ya eu cette année
la crasse
on de pâques pour que les touristes
quand il arrive sur tonnerre avant même
qu'ils arrivent d'ailleurs ils puissent
avoir un accompagnement touristique qui
fait qu'ils sont en quelque sorte pris
en un donc ce travail là qui est fait
continuellement créer une dynamique
globale et ça permet aussi derrière de
pouvoir tirer des investisseurs puisque
ce label petite cité de caractère n'a
pas qu'une retombée pour la collectivité
elle même elle a aussi une retombée pour
des partenaires les prestataires les
hébergeurs est donc amené les
investisseurs à dire 20 à tonnerre il ya
une dynamique globale
donc on peut rayonner beaucoup plus
facilement vous pensez qu'il y aura des
retombées qui seront mesurables d'ici
l'été prochain
bah écoutez quand on prend l'exemple je
prends l'exemple du guide du routard
puisqu'on on a cette chance qui le qu'il
aboutisse en 2017 sur les autres
territoires qui ont finalement bénéficié
de labels comme le guide du routard qui
en est en quelque sorte où une petite
cité de caractère
les chiffres laissent penser une
évolution de 30% ce qui est donc très
positif ce qui veut dire que on va créer
une dynamique est tout simplement on le
sait très bien le monde avec le monde
parce que comme à l'instar dans votre
reportage de la personne qui voulait
promouvoir tonnerre puisque elle en
était fier ces touristes là sont nos
premiers ambassadeurs auprès de leurs
amis et c'est pour ça que c'est très
important de pouvoir bénéficier de cette
mise en lumière du label petite cité de
caractère
merci beaucoup s'est fait cette mise en
lumière merci à vous l'occasion donc
d'aller visiter tonnerre et ses environs